so we're gonna have a look at this now
one of the reasons why we have
completing the square up our sleeve is
because many questions will resist the
ability to be factorized simply now I
just made this up but when you have a
look I'm kind of pair of numbers are you
trying to think of a pair of numbers
that adds to negative three and
multiplies to negative 16 I'm struggling
I'm struggling right now it may well
exist but the point is like just look at
the circle geometry question there's a
point which you say I don't need to
worry about fit like bashing my head in
floor I've got other strategies or other
things that I can go along with
completing square is one of them okay so
the first thing the very first thing we
do we complete the square is we need to
consider a monic version of this on
Monika version of it it's not Manik
right now because of the two so how do I
get rid of that 2 I'll divide everything
through so this equation here is
equivalent to the first one because it's
an equation so I've divide both sides by
2 or good once I've done this the whole
idea of completing the square is that
this thing in here if I add something if
I add just the right piece onto it it
becomes the square it's not right now
but I can turn it into one okay so being
that I'm only considering this part over
here I get this negative 4 and I don't
want it there so what led you to get rid
of I'll add 4 to both sides let's do
that ok
so you can see why I'm doing these steps
okay i-it's because I want to work with
something that's simpler I want to focus
on just this part of it here's the the
crucial the completing the square piece
I need to add something to both sides
that will turn this left-hand quadratic
into a square so the key is really this
number this number is you what do I have
to do some of you remembers I'm going to
have it and then I'm going to square it
Hobbit square it Hobbit square okay and
that number is what I will add to both
sides it's fine
okay so once I have this number this
number here I'm going to have 3/4 right
that's half that so what's the square of
that 9m is 16 so I'm going to write this
like that that step there is the step
that completing the square is named
after because now this thing on the left
hand side is a square it's going to be X
take away how do I know let's take away
by the way because of that right that
won't emerge unless I've got this here
right now I remember how you have done
then you squared you harder than you
squared when you have do it
you create a disturber right does that
make sense because this thing is the
square out of completing the square
which is why this is the it's the B
squared in a squared minus 2 a bit plus
B squared right
so when you have been squared it you've
got this but having it is what gives you
the number you need okay 4 plus 9 over
16 should we do something with that 70
it's an awkward number because I just
made this up
okay so this is good this is progress
because I have a factorization but I
haven't sold this have I so now almost I
do I will take the square root of both
sides now we remember that when you take
the square root of both sides you have
to remember that you're expecting two
solutions not one so on the right hand
side I'm going to have to say not just
root 73 on 4 I'm going to have to say
plus or minus
that number and now I'm pretty much
there aren't I I'm only one line away
what shall I do to both say fish I'll
add 3/4 so I'm going to go 3 plus or
minus ha ha and there are our solutions
thank goodness I didn't keep on staring
at that until I guessed 3 plus root 73
on 4 and 373 24 okay so this process is
useful because number one it deals with
when you can't just guess right number
two because it's where the quadratic
formula is born right the quadratic
formula is born when you do this process
to this guy that's what happens right if
we go through identical person you know
divide through with this guy over add
whatever you need to add and rearrange
then this is where you land okay lastly
one quick thing write this down on the
side for me
this guy here this is not a quadratic
nor is it a function but it's clearly
related to quadratics and it's clearly
related to functions if I asked you to
draw this what would it be this would be
a circle okay now at the moment in the
current form that it's in I know nothing
about this circle I'm gonna have to
rework this quite substantially in order
to work out where the temporaries work
out through the radiuses how am I going
to rework it answer with this tool right
we can quickly do this right now have a
look you can see here's a quadratic
function that makes it up here's another
one and then here's something which is
going to give me my radius eventually
once it's complete so have a look at
this
what will I add to that to complete the
square remember to do with this number
there's two things you have to do you
you have and square
Harve and square okay so once you have
you get one and then when you square
that you get one we're on a bad day
today oh that guy there how about this
one right you're going to have an square
so harvin gives you negative two
squaring gives you plus four okay we've
got at that time uh-hum plus four now to
make sure that this is balanced I'm
going to add 7 to both sides I don't
want it there I'm also going to add the
one that was here and I'm going to add
before that was here because I I
intended to add those in and now you can
see the next line which is factorized
now I can read every required feature of
this that I need right I know where the
center is where's the center the center
is at it mean scuse me negative 1 comma
C and I know that the radius is in this
case the radius will be 4 12
okay so in order to understand these
objects which is neither quadratic nor a
function you have to appeal to this
thing we know about quadratic functions
okay